thank you mr chairman and uh good
morning good morning to everyone yes we
have some language here that we would
like to present to the house
as
and hopefully that the house can adopt
the senate version with this amendment
proposed amendment
there is a new section 3 which is on the
back of
the
first
page that deals with
one of the objections that was raised
during the committee conference process
on tuesday dealing with
domestic violence
orders and the protections that would
need to be in place
for
individuals that have these orders
and the s at the next um proposed change
is on the second pay the third page
which is a savings provision
which states that if
in the event
that any of the terms or provisions of
this act
are declared invalid or unenforceable by
any court of competent jurisdiction the
remaining terms and provisions that are
now affected thereby shall remain in
full force in effect in construing this
provision a court shall make such ruling
in a manner that favors retaining the
enforceability of any remaining terms to
the greatest extent possible that is the
senate version of house bill 1431 that
we are standing behind and we ask that
the
house adopt our version thank you mr mr
uh chairman
uh thank you senator uh on this section
three the savings provision that seems
like something
you often see referred to as a
severability clause is there a
difference
there i've never seen this terminology
before okay no not at all
mr chair may i go ahead yes
thank you mr chair um
i also want to submit an amendment that
i passed out to all the members
um i do believe we're discussing this
amendment right now okay i just want to
make sure members had it
i will note on this amendment um
there have been significant concerns
raised about the
bill passed by the senate uh raised by
the lgbtq
community that have absolutely not been
addressed by this we are still going to
be
outing children
against their will
in schools
and potentially you know sending them
into a situation at home that we don't
know may be volatile maybe unaffirming
and i think that this bill is
antithetical to all the work we have
done
in the state to ensure
uh that individuals in this community in
the lgbt community can live a life free
from discrimination and and uh and be
safe in their own communities this is
antithetical to that and i'm i'm sorry
senator we're discussing this amendment
right now i am and i am speaking
uh mr chair to sec to num to section
let's see
excuse me mr chair 169 one f
uh g f
no yes g excuse me the the right to be
promptly notified and if you skip down
regarding the gender expression or
identities right there
that's the part that was identified to
us by national and local lgbt community
members as
deeply problematic mr chair can we
finish
one uh amendment at a time please well
no no i'm speaking
to this section g right here
any further discussion on that
not hearing none any further discussion
on any other part of this amendment mr
chair go ahead i will say also this is
antithetical to all the work that the
state has done to build a system of care
for children with mental health we have
right now a an elevated
number of children seeking mental health
just last time i checked we had 10
children waiting in emergency rooms for
care not able to get treatment and so
now we are going to elevate this problem
by creating situations where lgbt kids
are scared to go to school scared to be
added by their parents
and elevating issues we know that are uh
we know the lgbt community has
heightened mental health issues and
we're going to only make this better
go ahead the senator is speaking to
testimony that we did not get in the
committee and this is something that i
spoke about on tuesday
that all during this process
we have been open available to
individuals
this is a fight that we've already had
on the floor of the senate
and to bring it forward at this point i
think
is an attempt to derail this legislation
and i don't think it's appropriate but
you are the chair and you get to make
that ruling not not me
so i i i had offered potential language
um and i would like to see us um discuss
this language
this language change the underlying bill
has not changed these were just
additions
that
we heard especially on the domestic
violence that there were some concerns
made by the house and so we have
language here that we would like the
house to consider
thank you
we appreciate the senate attending to
the concerns of the house do you have
any
discussion
thank you mr chair i do
there's been information brought forward
concerning the fact that some of the
employees
of a school district may have
conversations with children
and those employees
are not licensed
to
discuss these issues with these children
these employees are
employees of the community in which
they attend that school
the taxpayer is the potential boss
or a person who pays their salaries
so i do agree
that if it is an unlicensed person that
these children spoke to
it is not their responsibility to
withhold that information
from anyone
if a child needs psychiatric care they
need to go to the school psychiatrist
i
i like
um
roman numeral three
and section three
that the senate has proposed to us
uh and that's at this time off i have to
say
all right thank you representative any
further discussion yes mr chair
i think uh let's let senator gannon have
a turn sure i'll just go back to g
because that was what we were discussing
um all the parents i know myself
included parent of four public school
kids graduates and still attending we
want to know what's going on with our
kids i trust in the parents of new
hampshire unless there's a specific
issue that needs to deal with a mandated
reporter i want to know everything going
on in my kids life as much as possible
i'm the one there from cradle to grave i
encourage them the most the 15 or 20
teachers that are different every year a
different group they don't have the
caring interests they don't know my
child like i do i'm the one responsible
for them the child doesn't have capacity
in his own to give up whether or not
he's going to get certain medical
treatment i want to know what's going on
in my kid's life so do the people in new
hampshire thank you i think so i think
it's uh pretty clear that when children
do need help their best chance of
getting that is when their parents know
what's going on right
senator
thank you mr chair and i agree i am i'm
a mom myself i want to know what's going
on with my child and i work with my
school to to do that but the problem is
is that not every child has a safe home
not every child has safe parents i have
spent my career trying to protect
children and
and this is again antithetical to the
safety of children and i will note that
you know just two years ago just two
years ago
we amended as a legislature uh rsa 169
c2 and we said that
in in in this is the child protection
statute that we need to provide for the
best interest of the child and the child
shall be the primary consideration
right so this isn't moving this was an
important
bipartisan move to prioritize the needs
of our state's most vulnerable
population and we are going backwards we
know that our lgbt youth are some of our
most vulnerable and we know that not all
of them have safe homes we know
that some of their parents are not
accepting we know that many are
accepting but why would we do something
to jeopardize the safety of children
right now i also want to say that of
course i believe in parents fundamental
rights i am a parent myself i understand
i know so many wonderful parents but we
this whole bill there's nothing in here
nothing about the interests of children
nothing in here about a child's right to
safety nothing in here about a child's
right to receive an
education and i just fear that
like the exclusion of any children's
rights is going to elevate parental
rights over that of children and i find
that so sad and so problematic okay
senator carson
thank you mr mr chair um
i think we have debated this issue
at length
during the
house hearing during the senate hearing
on the senate floor
we can't i i just can't see
to keep debating this issue over and
over and over again and i think it's
time for
for us to make a decision
uh you know i think you're correct and i
uh allowed a little bit of latitude here
since there are fresh faces behind the
table today
and uh i think uh we've had enough at
this point uh how does the house uh feel
about this amendment are we are we good
with it
i will be grudgingly concur
it can come
yeah so the house uh agrees with this
amendment okay
thank you very much
are there any further amendments to
discuss today
i do have an amendment i would like to
bring forward
uh i
guess we will entertain that thank you
um
so there is an amendment here
this is something that we had this is
not new this is something we have
discussed you'll see that the amendment
has two separate parts um everyone
should have in front of them the first
one is in recognition of the important
parental rights
that we have already in state law and i
think that's an important thing to note
parents already have
very clear constitutional rights
statutory rights and other rights
defined elsewhere and so this uh
amendment requires the department of
health and human services the department
of education to collate all those rights
into one places which is my
understanding the why people wanted this
bill in the first place collate all
these rights in one place and make that
available to the public plain and simple
the second part of the amendment creates
a commission
to study the parental rights you'll see
that it has broad membership including
parents and administrators and child
advocates it's a more balanced approach
because we are all not only thinking
about parents rights but we're thinking
about children's rights
and you'll see that all the duties uh on
page two
of the commission
talk about exactly what is in the bill
all these things that people are
concerned with let's talk about it in a
thoughtful way
we have heard
opposition to this bill from new futures
from
uh the coal the coalition we from uh
teachers union from a broad coalition of
people from so many parents i have
gotten hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of parents who are opposed to
this bill
let's explore all the unintended uh
unintended consequences let's look at
this in a thoughtful way
in a thoughtful way and make sure we are
not harming children so i think this is
a very good step forward and i hope the
committee can support it
okay i do believe we've been uh looking
at this issue in a thoughtful way now
for a number of months and i do believe
that uh all of us have uh received
hundreds or thousands of emails uh from
parents uh on on this issue
senator thank you mr chairman i would
like to point out this news the section
dealing with
the parental rights guidebook um this
was presented as a floor amendment uh in
the senate it died 12 to 12. so this
idea was not supported by the senate so
this side of the table cannot support
even recommending this to the house
thank you i'm pretty sure the house
has the same
point of view representatively simone is
that correct
that is correct mr chair okay thank you
are there any other further amendments
that we wish to discuss
are we ready to take a vote yes on the
bill
uh does the house exceed to the uh
senate position
i'd be grudgingly a seed
yes
uh the house succeeds to the senate on
h.b 431 with the amendment brought
forward today by senator carson
thank you very much mr chairman and
thank you house member
you